well as restaurants continue to have  problems finding workers  are also facing now food and beverage  shortages  a lot of them say distributors are  scrambling to get certain types of  alcohols and food items back in stock  the owner of crazy peta says getting  chicken for these three locations has  not been easy  the vendor he uses has had to find a new  place to get it from  we have been facing some shorters in  many areas  product shoulders as so many companies  are struggling to find the labor  transportation at the restaurant level  with for example we've been having  chicken issues it's like a perfect storm  of obstacles there some restaurant  owners tell us there are shortages on  certain bottles of alcohol as well  forcing them just to go ahead and change  the brand many say an increase in demand  and supply chain shortages are to blame